[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen my name is nico
watson and i'm peter jobs and we have an
exciting announcement for you today now
we've been making cameras for years but
nobody's been buying them
i couldn't figure out why and then it
hit me we have the perfect camera right
here in our heads so we can make a
camera that exceeds the specifications
the human eye
will be billionaires so i am pleased to
announce today
the eye camera a camera with
specifications that beat the human
eyeball
peter jobs please tell us more about
what these specifications are
i thought you brought specifications oh
that was your job no i got this hurdle
next you get specifications okay
look you're the one who makes all the
engineers cry because you're working so
hard so why don't you get on the phone
nobody cries more than i do so don't
come with me
okay okay it's enough we're just gonna
come back at the end of the video
specifications let's get those engineers
working on it right now
is that an android
[Music]
so when peter jobs came to me and said
hey i need you to make the perfect
camera that can exceed the human eye
i don't even know where to begin what
kind of specs i need to figure out and i
figured resolution was a good one to
start with do you know what the
resolution of the human eye is that's a
complicated question
and with a complicated answer but i have
some cool experiments we can try i think
we should compare
the resolution of our eyes to the best
camera we have in the studio which is
the red and come back and figure out
what these numbers are going to be so
here we have
a red gemini which has a 5k sensor so
the real question i want to answer with
this experiment is just how our eye
stacks up to the cinema camera now
there's two ways we can look at this
one is you have your field of vision
right right about here
is where my hands disappear on the edges
of my vision it's basically 180 degrees
can't really see individual fingers
wiggling until i'm about here
120 140 something like that so if we
could look at the entire field of vision
but in reality our eyes actually have a
certain central area of high resolution
called the
fovea imagine the full moon up in the
sky it's a little bit bigger than that
that's how big
your high detailed center of your vision
is so first things first we're going to
figure out what the equivalent of our
field of view is on this camera so
11 millimeters that's actually pretty
close so i have our camera set to just
give us the entire sensor
here for our image we're not cropped in
at all so we're hitting about 95 to 100
degrees for field of view right now but
in real life what i can see with my
eyes that looks straight ahead it's
definitely a little bit wider pretty
close to 180 i'm going to call it like
170 165.
some people's eyes [ __ ] he's
probably like a five millimeters like
190 degree field of view
this is about as close as we can get to
an accurate wide angle estimation of our
field of view so we'll start with this
for our resolution test here's what i'm
going to propose we draw two lines on a
piece of paper and we go
back and back and back until we can no
longer visually tell that the two
separate lines and just click one line
we're gonna do the same thing on the
camera with the same field of view
and see at what point the camera can no
longer distinguish between the two lines
as well
will you walk and then i'm gonna tell
you at what point i can no longer see
two individual lines how many lines are
there
two i can still tell it's two lines hmm
right about there stop that looks like
one solid line to me
you see one for sure one thick one i
think that's a fat
one line that's the point there at which
our eyeballs are seeing
these two lines right next to each other
as one line so now let's see what the
camera can see
we are projecting a 15 degree field of
view onto a 5k
sensor so our eyes can see basically 200
pixels
per degree of field of vision and our
central phobia is roughly 15 degrees
so that is a 3k sensor let's see
at what point this stops resolving the
two lines all right we're passing the
human threshold here
yep i can still see them easy you still
tell yeah
easy easy man
okay i think i can see it so what we
discovered here is that when you match
the red camera to the central part of
our fovea the red camera actually beats
the human eye but when you match the red
camera to our overall vision
our clarity beats the red camera if you
were to attribute the resolution that
you see in your fovea
to your entire field of view your entire
field of view would be 576
megapixels which is nuts that's not
quite realistic and it's not an accurate
representation of our isar solution
either so
middle ground a good middle ground
that's to your eyes and you kind of
factor in your central phobia detail and
all the rest of the detail around your
eye
you're looking at basically creating an
image your mind it's about 130
megapixels
pretty dang good right it's really dang
good the next thing we had to figure out
was frame rate peter do you have any
idea what the frame rate is that we can
see
i don't know maybe 60 probably past 60
right because you can tell the
difference from a 60 frames per second
video to 120 frames per second video
can you i guess we got to find out
anyways we're going to be doing an
experiment here we have a tv here that's
running smash brothers at 60 frames per
second and there's a mode you can turn
on
to up res that temporal resolution to
120 frames per second we're going to
show people
option a in option b and we're not going
to tell them which is which we're going
to ask them
which one is the higher frame rate
that's 120. he's right
yeah i smelled the frames so it turns
out only three out of five people can
actually tell the difference between
60 hertz and 120 hertz what do you take
from that nikko
you have to have a relatively trained
eye to be able to pick up on that kind
of high frame rates but
under half the test subjects couldn't
tell the difference so what it does tell
me is that there is a diminishing
returns that you start to approach as
you
get to 120 hertz and higher so the
question is what kind of frame rates can
the eye actually see well
your eye basically has an independent
frame rate for each
pixel in the eye so there is an actual
theoretical limit to your frame rate
your neurons basically can fire at 13
milliseconds
that's the max amount of time you have
one neuron in your eye like a cone
detect some light and then
shoot some light to your brain how many
frames does 13 milliseconds equate to
75 frames per second they're all
slightly offset from each other it's one
chaotic mush a blur of 75 frames per
second that are happening all over the
place and here's a crazy thing so they
actually did an experiment with pilots
where they flashed
an image up on the screen they were
seeing how short the image could be
and still have the pilots identify what
kind of airplane was in the picture
and the fastest they were able to flash
the image was 1 220
of a second we at least have the vision
of 220 frames per second
once again that's an oversimplification
but i think we're going to make the eye
camera stack up to the human eye
we need to exceed 500 frames per second
come here come here peter uh
just come on in come on in shut the door
turn off the light what are you doing
man
being completely honest i feel like my
unveiling of the product this morning
was
a bit stale what better way to practice
unveiling revolutionary technology than
with today's sponsor
raycon i really got work no no just
drop a light are you ready
hello and welcome my name is ray khan
and this is raycon con 2020. we've been
hearing a lot about the
eyes this crew episode but you know what
we haven't been hearing about
the ears
i would like to unveil the everyday e25
raycon earbuds raycon earbuds are both
stylish and discreet with no tangling
wires or stems
these puppies sound just as amazing as
any other audio brands
you know steve didn't swear okay sorry
so unprofessional i'm sorry these
puppies sound just as amazing as other
top audio brands you know plus
they come in a variety of interesting
and unique colors
to make your ears shine like a diamond
that's pretty good these earbuds give
you six hours of play time
seamless bluetooth integration more bass
and more compact design for comfortable
fit
and noise isolation
they also come with a compact carrying
case
that charges them on the go and if
you're thinking about snagging some of
these
beautiful earbuds now is the time
because
if you go to buy recon dot com slash
corridor or click the link in the
description you can get 20
off with code corridor crew
if you want some of these go to buy
raycon.com corridor crew for 20
off your way thank you it's been a
pleasure and uh
good listening
okay later
all right so now we have the third thing
we need to figure out which is what is
the light sensitivity of the human eye
what's the iso wait where's peter wait
where is peter
hey man sorry i had to return some
videotapes all right what are we talking
about
anyways cameras have a certain amount of
light that they're optimally tuned for
does our eye have a certain amount of
light that we're optimally tuned for in
addition to that cameras have different
modes they might have a regular light
mode they might have a low light mode
they might have a night vision mode so i
have an idea for an experiment we should
do
i've learned that our default aperture
of our eye when it's pretty much all the
way open
is a 3.2 f-stop how'd you even figure
that out man
just divide your aperture diameter by
your focal length to get your
f-stop so what we're going to do is
we're going to take a camera and set it
to 24 frames per second we're going to
give it a 1 over 48 shutter so 180
degrees shutter
and set the lens to 3.2 so it matches
our eyes f-stop
then we're going to see it what iso does
the image from the camera and the amount
of data it's getting
match what we can see with our eyeballs
we're going to do this in regular light
in low light and we're going to do this
in night vision
about iso 800 iso 640 or so
iso 640 about matches we're going to do
our low light experiment we're going to
come in here
turn off the lights let the light from
the skylight come in and daniel's going
to join us with this a7 which has
a much much higher iso range than the
red for us to kind of see
what matches our eyesight then we're
going to do our night vision test we're
going to go into a almost pitch black
room and give our eyes at least five
minutes to adjust in real life
30 minutes is what you need to get full
night vision but we're going to do about
five minutes until we can kind of see
then we're gonna see where that's at so
we learned some pretty interesting
things
before you enter low light mode with
your eyes you can get up to about a
thousand iso in terms of sensitivity
another crazy thing is before your it
gets too bright and your eyes can't
underexpose anymore your aperture can't
close any farther and
you know you're not blown out to white
you can go all the way down to one iso
your eyes have a daylight range from one
iso to a thousand iso which is pretty
incredible
i don't know any camera that can go down
to one iso i don't either
now when it comes to low light our
native iso is 16 000.
it took a camera at 16 000 iso to match
the brightness that we see with our eyes
in like a low light setting now night
vision
is pretty crazy we discovered that we
needed to go to 800
000 iso to match our eyes at night
vision so our cameras have a one to one
thousand daylight iso range he's have 16
000 low light and 800 000 night vision
800 000 baby
so we were tasked with figuring out the
dynamic range in the human eyeball what
is dynamic range
there's a certain point where something
so bright just clips out to white that's
the high end
there's a certain part where stuff is
just noisy and dark the range between
those two points
is referred to as dynamic range and i
have an interesting experiment we can
try to discover
the dynamic range of our eyeball
compared to our red camera
what we'll be doing is we'll be shining
a very very bright light on a wall and
we'll be getting it so bright that it's
clipping
in our eyes and we can't make it any
brighter otherwise we won't be able to
see any detail once we've done that
we're going to hold up a phone screen in
front of it we're going to lower the
brightness from the phone screen until
it's just
on the threshold of perceptible detail
then we're going to use the red camera
which has something called geoscopes
that shows us all the stops the camera
is sensing we're going to see just how
big of a difference in light values
between that bright spot on the wall
and the phone screen that we're dealing
with well we had some interesting
results and the experiment actually
worked pretty well
the answer is 21 stops roughly in fact
this is backed up with some research i
did so someone else is trying to figure
out the dynamic range of the human eye
and the way they did it is they had
somebody look up at the full moon
and there's actually a measurement for
how bright the moon is when it's full
and then while keeping their eye on the
full moon
they had them identify the dimmest star
that was generally within that same kind
of circle around the full moon that star
is also of course
charted with its brightness and by
measuring the brightness difference
between those two points
they came up with a contrast ratio of a
million to one that the i could see from
one to a million in terms of the
contrast ratio which happens to be
20 stops of dynamic range correlates
with our findings
it's theorizing i can see more than 20
stops of course but in terms of like an
accurate scientific measurement that was
a pretty good way to do it kind of
aligns with our findings
so we definitely need to make sure that
the eye camera has at least i'm going to
say 21 stops of dynamic range yeah we
could do that
so i went back into peter jobs's office
and i presented him the i camera
what'd he say he said it's okay we need
some bonus features because we gotta
mark this thing everyone's like well you
know
real eyeballs see in 3d we got
stereoscopic vision he's like that's
great pack two of them in the box well
we'll sell it as a set 3d so guess what
real eyes actually have stabilization
our eyes have tremors at 75 to 110 hertz
that means
75 to 110 times per second your eye is
constantly twitching and stabilizing
so we have optical stabilization in the
eye camera
not only that you got a blind spot in
your eye that's right there's a spot
where your nerve is attached to the back
your eye it's just a blind spot you
can't see anything but your brain is
constantly doing content aware fill for
dead pixels
i guess we just screwed up and we didn't
put a sensor there so
you can actually test that out if you
look at one finger you keep moving your
hand closer to your face eventually
the tip of your other finger will
disappear yeah pretty cool
and then that's all well and good i was
like wait but what about the recording
format media cards
hard drives he's like a picture it's a
personal experience
it's an emotional experience so when you
take a picture of the eye camera only
you get to see it
and from that point forwards the only
way to share that photo is to describe
it to somebody else
[Laughter]
that is beautiful that this product
promotes social interaction oh yeah and
just like our memories in the picture
degrades over time and sometimes things
get added to it that weren't really
there
it's all kind of wonky and even if you
record a video you can only like
get a brief snapshot of it if you play
the video back so there we have it
that's what our research has healed
for the eye camera i think we're going
to sell like a lot of these i'm honestly
scared to bring these
up to peter jobs he's gonna tear us a
new one maybe or
give us a little kiss on the cheek
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen we've done it we
are pleased to announce
the eye camera with a resolution of 130
megapixels
that's an image of 20 000 pixels by six
and a half thousand pixels
and a sort of full frame 35 millimeter
sensor with a frame rate of at least 500
frames per second
we are pleased to announce that i camera
boasts a dynamic range of 21 stops
and it also has multiple iso settings
such as
16 000 in low light one to one thousand
in daylight
and 800 000 in night vision night vision
might be a monochromatic blue but don't
worry about that it's artsy with other
bonus features such as lens
stabilization
content aware fill stereoscopic 3d
vision and
custom skins it comes in blue hazel
green that's it so there you have it a
revolutionary new camera that meets the
specifications of the human eyeball
available only nine months after the
conception of your purchase at corridor
digital.com to place a pre-order hit the
subscribe button ring that little
notification bell
and leave a comment down below with what
color you would like what color are you
going to go with nico
i'm going to go with the green same
and veils
well all right head on over to
quarterdoodle.com
to check out an exclusive vlog okay see
you later